ce jeudi qu emma 15 mars e journée
nationale de mobilisation des retraités
contre la baisse de leur pouvoir d'achat
contre la hausse de la csg louis maugée
de la cgtm est avec nous en tant que
porte parole de cette intersyndicale qui
compte six centrales locales bonjour
louis maugée bonjour maurizio le temps
matière syndicale qui ici en martinique
s'adresse d'abord aux parlementaires car
ce sont eux qui votent les lois que leur
demandez vous puisque vous les avez
rencontré en début de semaine alors oui
alors dans un premier temps je vais
quand même dire le front syndical commun
il est constitué il est constitué de la
fédération générale des retraités de la
fonction publique de la cgtm de la cdmt
de la cgtm fsm du fsu et de la cftc
donc l'intention c'est de dire
aujourd'hui qu'on ouvre un front
syndical de manière à nous interpeller
nous mêmes nos organisations syndicales
mais aussi interprète interpellé les
milliers de retraités et de personnes
âgées qui se trouvent dans les
associations et qui pousse aujourd'hui
en tout cas ne se sentent pas un petit
peu concerné par une mobilisation contre
la politique de main les retraités c'est
quand même un quart de la population
martiniquaise et il faut le rappeler les
romans et essais c'est près de 500 mille
personnes
et quand on sait qu'à l'origine à
l'horizon de 2040 il sort en 135 milles
on imagine la force que ça représente
c'est surtout une force que ça
représente et cette force là notre
ambition c'est de la mobiliser alors
qu'avez vous dit aux parlementaires que
vous avez rencontré lundi dernier alors
aux parlementaires nous leur avons
précisément dit qu' il est profondément
injuste que le banquier devenu président
que monsieur mac on s'attaque aux
retraités parce que on ne peut pas faire
l'impasse sur l' isf qu'il impose la
fortune et puis venir piquer dans la
caisse du roi de fuite et 250 euros
c'est un petit peu ce qu'il faut
comptabilisées pour une retraite de 1200
euros 1.727 g en fin d'année ça fait 250
euros et puis ce n'est pas que ça parce
que par le passé on a vu effectivement
que les retraités ont été soumis à une
fonction de 0 3% de las casas on a vu
que les retraites n'ont pas été
revalorisés non plus on a vu que au lieu
que les retraites soient indexés sur
l'évolution des salaires et bien les
indexé sur l'évolution du coût de la vie
et de l'inflation
tout ça c'est la politique de dowland et
avant lui de sarkozy mâcon le relais
toujours dans le même but
assommés les retraités est ce que vous
avez entendu les explications de du
président macron face à des retraités
qui leur disaient tout simplement il
faut savoir attendre il faut savoir être
patient il faut surtout aider les
générations actuelles qui travaillent
parce que ce grâce à ce travail là que
les retraites actuelles seront versés
dont priorité à ceux qui travaillent
ma foi est un sale hypocrites les
retraités ils donnent de leur vie ils
donnent de l'autre
et puis pour bénéficier de la retraite
ils ont travaillé ils ont rempli deux
conditions avoir l'âge et avoir
comptabilisé un certain nombre de
trimestre pour se faire liquider nous
pensions hier j'écoutais jimmy dans son
émission où il a reçu des jeunes qui ont
mis en place une association pour
justement entraide et le bénévolat est
bien les retraités s'il ya des gens qui
sont investis dans le bénévolat au
quotidien si l'épicentre de la
solidarité se trouvant quelques passes
et si le retraité
c'est eux qui animent des associations
c'est un cas ni les familles c'est un
qui font de la cohésion dans leur
quartier et ses retraités l'aca ces gens
là que ma conversant points et puis
libère les sfd blanquier vous savez
cette politique là où ça a mené sa mené
qu'aujourd'hui environ nous on nous
indique que le 84-81 13,4 milliards
d'euros sont les profits réalisés par
les entreprises du cac 40
voilà la politique de main alors limogé
au cape town aussi macro quitter qu'à
disséminant quitté dubaï l'un des autres
critiques idiot mais c'est au travail
tous à temps c'était surtout coûté payer
aux retraites c'est moi qui tu es là
avant yom est ce qu'on attend de
baguettes à la wii mais mâcon ica
quartier royal est
problème la vôtre creed si aujourd'hui
que les entreprises pack embaucher ces
jo dijoux que c'est justement side effet
il est à lyon mais tu es accents de ses
mines anti-chars crier la vie chaque
année doit pouvoir oui mais si les
entreprises travaillent ils nient quand
vous mais des chantiers regardez comment
qu'attendent aujourd'hui jouent les
collectivités cadiot panne ou l'agent
effectivement y prélever 50 milliards en
laye aux messieurs valls à l'époque e
books était bas les entreprises ni ses
gars tu as pour l'argent mexico ayant un
emploi
le patronat pas cru en emploi jeudi jour
là ce thème car souffrait aux cahiers au
passage une raison de 10 à les
collectivités cabré puis au bas d'un
agent llopez pas fait fonctionner les
collectivités correctement l'opep a
embauché want you pay pas lancer des
travaux
et ça c'est politique de l'état pour qui
l'état qu'après la jambe il s'est pété
utilisé pour ça pour la population pour
les citoyens car dans les entreprises
ion est calibré lisf jo dijoux fauque
savent que la deuxième porte une de
france c'est 40 milliards de bénéfices
40 milliards d'intérêts 40 milliards de
bonification la deuxième fortune ni
l'agent ici à athènes en tunique alliés
dominent en face la maison des syndicats
à l'institut d'émission des départements
d'outre-mer ni un milliard can aux mille
à 1 milliard dépendent du cac et sa
localité comme de liesse f
l'actif des ménages et l'actif des
entreprises en milliards dont les
pradino vanilla jean louis maugée louis
maugée il ya la situation d'hier aux
critiques qu'on s'est mis lui aussi des
spécificités pour nos retraités de
martinique des minima sociaux beaucoup
plus faibles et ils sont beaucoup plus
nombreux qu'en france alors
effectivement il faut soulever la
question et le mouvement on en profite
pour dire qu' il est indécent de voir
aujourd'hui on demande à des
travailleurs qui toute leur vie ont
travaillé de se satisfaire d'une
retraite de 300 de 400 euros
voilà voir un moyen pour le régime
général c'est 646 sentent 646 euros pour
le régime général en moyen en france et
1300 euros
eh bien pourquoi ces 300 euros pourquoi
les gens sont sont soumis à la spa qui
est une allocation spécifique ou
ou à la au minimum vieillesse c'est tout
simplement parce que ils ont travaillé
toute leur vie
ces gens là simplement ils ont eu des
salaires insuffisants ou bien ils ont
travaillé effectivement pour des patrons
qui ne veut pas déclarés donc on se
retrouve bien des périodes de mon
activité dont on se retrouve avec des
retraités qui n'ont pas les moyens de
vivre alors que toute leur vie ils ont
travaillé ils n'ont pas les moyens parce
que le salé la retraite de professeur ou
de 400 euros est insuffisant quand on
sait qu'en loyers hlm c'est 400 euros
pour un f3 et en plus on assiste à une
concentration puisque grand moment la
tradition micheli kylie même les dix
lits et arrière petit fils lee ça aussi
ce sont des choses qu'il faut faire
comprendre et les parlementaires que
vous avez reçus ils vous ont dit quoi
ils vont entendre des mots qui finit en
ligne et aux côtés et puis viré pâtit
alors nous avons deux parlementaires qui
sont venus et deux qui se sont excusés
nouvelle madame man s est excusé et
madame conde s'est excusé parce qu'il
devait intervenir sur le professional il
est deux qui étaient là s'émeut
scientiste et monsieur ni l'eau ils ont
tous les deux compris parce que ils ont
bien en tête parce que heavy aussi sur
le territoire illusions et vivent et
pensent qu'il co 3 aussi ces
personnes-là et leurs propositions c'est
bien entendu de me dire qu'ils vont
soutenir la revendication qui consiste à
dire on va revaloriser les minima
sociaux
on va revaloriser les petites pensions
on va rattraper les 20 2% d'un pouvoir
d'achat qu'on a perdu sur les sept
dernières années il y a même un qui nous
a proposé de faire passer une motion au
niveau de la ctm pour qu' il y ait de
notre succès sur jean-philippe nord qui
sport consensus de l'ensemble des élus
pour établir qui a une prise de
conscience de cette cruelle face à cela
il y à emmanuel macron il ya le
gouvernement de d'edouard philippe ça va
pas changer grand chose ça va changer
les choses si effectivement la
mobilisation puissante
tout à l'heure vous rappeler que nous
étions effectivement un quart de la
population
cent mille personnes si on arrive à
cette ambition de les mobiliser
on se fera entendre bien entendu il y a
quelqu'un qui disait mais si les
retraités se mettait à faire la grève du
bénévolat
si les retraités se mettaient à ne pas
entretenir la cohésion dans la cité si
les retraités ne s'investissent pas dans
les 10 à 6 réalisé sans ce serait ce
serait une manière visible de voir là
l'importance qu'ils ont au sein de la
société
parce que que dit monsieur monsieur main
contre monsieur minc ont dit que les
otites et son sont des assistés c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi cette manière de
mépriser ceux qui ont toute leur vie
travailler ça ressemble à mâcon de dire
ça puisque il traitait les travailleurs
de fainéants mais est-ce que non
contente d'être porté au pouvoir
louis maugée cela on n'y peut rien de
besoin d'investir davantage le cnpac
nous on n'y peut rien parce que c'est
qui va justement à l'arrêter donc nous
serons le rappeler au moment où de
mettre le bulletin de vote
louis maugée de faire le choix est de
faire le bon choix vous voulez investir
les associations là on retrouve beaucoup
de retraités est ce que vous adresser
également à ceux qui travaillent
aujourd'hui les actifs qui sont des
futurs retraités forcément alors bien
entendu la vocation des organisations
syndicales c'est d'être dans les
entreprises et d'être dé l'organisation
fait cheap des organisations de
retraités c'est d'être des sections au
sein des syndicats d'actifs donc il n'ya
pas de problème
les voies de fait et continue à défendre
leurs intérêts qui sont parfois
professionnelle au sein des syndicats
d'actifs et nous essayons de porter
notre notre intention de mobilisation
auprès des retraités qui dans la vie
civile sont des citoyens qui agissent
pour le bien commun
nous essaierons de leur dire que la
priorité des miens combien c'est de
défendre leurs intérêts qui sont
aujourd'hui attaquée par le gouvernement
mâcon et l'intersyndicale des retraités
c'est déjà une première vous avez
rencontré des parlementaires vous
mobiliser ce matin à 9 heures à la
maison des syndicats merci d'avoir été
avec nous limogeant rappelle que en
l'occurrence didier porte parole de cet
éther syndicale des retraités bonne
journée merci merci de m'avoir invité et
puis j'appelle tous les retraités à
venir nous rejoindre dès 9 heures
la maison des syndicats
[Musique]